I don't know John you know it uh life is
strange man and uh you know I figure
pick a set of morals pick a destination
paint a vision don't be afraid to revise
it from time to time but follow it man
you know because if you're not you're
full of
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
if if you ever wanted to do you know
your show here I think you know we could
do that play in conjunction we could
both you know we we could do it kind of
back to back that would be uh I think it
would be really cool really uh cool and
I you know be honored uh
work in the same venue uh so to speak
with you I mean for me too super
successful man I think like I told you
earlier you're now I've given you the
title of the guy that's in every movie
he's ever been made now that used to be
Robert
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's funny did you
feel like one role pushed you over the
top uh and you know what was that role
now I'm doing the interviewing now yeah
yeah hey man it can be whatever it can
be you know Joe I think um
you know I don't know I I I think uh for
me you know we were talking about your
experience over over in Spain that you
just had
you know there's so many times I think
in in the beginning of my first of all
the beginning is all just you know
clawing and scraping and crying in your
pillow because it's never gonna
happen why was I born with this big
nose why my ears look like
goddamn Dumbo the elephant and and
and uh but but that's part of the
qualities that make you stand out well
look man I think I think you know I I
think I'm not saying you got big no no
no no no it's not that it's just that
you know I I think that you know there's
a long time where you just
for me where it was a real a real
struggle and it wouldn't look like it
was going to happen and you know the
truth is I'm just as hungry now as I I
was then
um and I think that's
part of your success I would imagine for
I would imagine for all of us I think I
think like hunger and drive and being
humble and I you know I you know
eventually when we're gonna actually get
into this interview and talk about use
which I want to tell but like I'm sure
you probably had a lot of that same
thing I think I think you know with with
this thing because you you know you're
you're an Entertainer as well you know I
I think there's this misconception that
there's going to be this one thing
that's going to break you through and
every time I felt oh man this one
audition like it all comes down to this
like I gotta get this or oh now I got
this and this is going to break me
through it never really happens I I I
think it it's uh it's much more about
um you know your work ethic and and and
and and and who you are what why you're
working and what you stand for and not
compromising not changing who you are
and over time I think people both the
audience but but also your your peers
and your colleagues say you know that
works hard he shows up he
brings the best out of everybody he
doesn't complain he doesn't you know
he's always driving to make it better
and so look I think I think everything
in my life kind of changed around
walking dead
but I think a lot of that was also
because I I really became a new man and
I was focused on on different things you
know not changing who you are is maybe
the most difficult aspect of getting
notoriety of whether whether you're
famous or inFAMOUS
not changing who you are and not losing
the vision that you have uh because you
know you create that vision and you
follow it and sometimes you have to
alter it uh with the times it's every
decade you know I have a child from
every decade and uh each child is
different I bet to the decade I bet you
know
I uh gauge uh how the world is changing
by how they perceive things wow I think
back to my my daughter who's a criminal
lawyer she represented you she got me
out of many jams and I go back to her
she's 50 one now wow to my youngest 19
you know and he has a completely
different uh perspective of things but
it seems to be circling back uh you know
my oldest daughter's somewhat
conservative
my other two children more liberal and
my youngest is circling back more
conservative I've had a really great
lawyer Barry tarlow was a
criminal lawyer he's passed away
rated one of the top 10 lawyers in the
world and uh you know he said
things pivot back and forth like a
pendulum you know Society does interests
do with people
and I kind of got off track but no I've
but I've heard that exact thing you know
it's funny we you know one of the one of
the first guys I had on here is a is a
cop from East Baltimore grew up in East
Baltimore he's one of the most sort of
legendary cops uh you know drug cops and
Street Cops been plain close guy forever
in Baltimore he's one of these guys I
did a ton of ride-alongs with him and I
was out there on the street with him
he's one of those guys that all the cops
kind of look up to and respect but also
all the guys on the street do as well
right and uh he's a difficult position
to get in yeah exactly but like
he says the same thing about the
pendulum and he talks about specifically
with crime and and with sort of like you
know being sort of a liberal agenda on
crime would be tough on crime and how it
goes back and forth you know you said
something a second ago about you know
the hardest thing to do is sort of
remain staying who you are and you know
you're such a a fascinating guy to me
for so many different reasons but
you know I imagine for you that doing
that specifically you know when we met I
think we met outside the gym we did for
the first time and I saw you walking and
and like you know I think we'd walk by
each other a couple times we kind of
gave each other a head not and I was
like I don't know who that guy is but
that's a real good like that that guy's
no but there was something about like
the way you you you handled yourself and
then when we got to talking I heard wow
okay that's one of the most you know one
of the most infamous you know Hells
Angels of all time and he ran the
Ventura Chapter and he was one of the
leaders in the in the whole organization
and then
you know and and and and then I heard
you know you're out of the club now and
I I I I can't
you know made a lot of people unhappy
exactly and and I've heard that as well
and I imagine like being just I I really
obviously I want to go through your
journey and what you're about but being
yourself are you
are you the same guy now that you were
then and and and and and how have you
how have you managed that I I believe I
am the same guy I'm a little bit more
seasons a little bit more educated uh
and you know the
biblical point for me was we were
becoming the people we rebelled against
and that's just something that I
couldn't stay on board for and uh how so
specifically well
initially when I came around the Hell's
Angels the question marks and Satan
slaves the goblin Goose all these
different Southern California bike clubs
who were initially World War II veterans
that's you know the whole Southern
California was really the birthplace for
uh of the whole Outlaw bike scene and
you know it's a phenomena that is spread
all around the world now and uh it was
kind of a Live and Let Live uh attitude
and uh I think that uh as people develop
money and power
it affected them and not always in a
good way what specifically because I
know you went you you sort of laid down
your patch and you were you were the
longest you you were the longest sort of
serving president Charter president
president right in the in the Hell's
Angels yeah in the history 35 years a
leader of first in Los Angeles which was
a real experience because in the midst
of my tenure down there we've gotten the
war with the Mongols which was uh no
joke I mean you know it's interesting
people I was a marine and you know
worked for the Department of Defense
afterwards and you know people would say
well did you know did you have you ever
did you go to war and I said well I
didn't go to war in Vietnam but I went
to war in Southern California and and
look man there's nothing here where I
want you know I'm not after like
salacious like you you know but but what
we're just talking no I know brother but
you know I'm just really curious you
know I'm I'm pretty good friends with
Mel Chansey you know what I mean and uh
you know like but but this is a world
man I grew up in DC uh you know we
didn't have
I had no until I kind of came out here I
had no real exposure to this world have
friends in it I've known guys on all
sides of everything it's a it's a a big
thing that I'm sure you believe in as
well I I got I I judge people only by
the content of their character
absolutely you know and I I have a lot
of police officers that I consider
friends and I was criticized uh by a lot
of club members even when I uh was in
good standing and at the you know peak
of my power a lot of people didn't like
the relationship I have but it was a
unique relationship back in the 70s and
the 80s in Ventura you know Ventura
Police Department was very small I knew
all officers there was an interesting uh
street cop he worked by himself his name
was cubic and he would
really expect the Hell's Angels to
control the street yeah and uh of you
know they turn their uh Blind Eye to a
lot of things if it in fact helped the
community and the interesting thing
about this guy cubic was he was a Green
Beret major and he lived up in the
mountains uh in Vietnam and he came down
he probably could have ran uh for chief
of police at some point he had a
lustrous long career but he never got
any Rank and he never had a partner he
was a solo guy you know just an old
school guy and I respected him and he
respected us and uh you know that has
changed you asked me earlier what has
changed that's one of the things that
changed was respecting somebody
just for them for them what they do and
that's the thing I think with this with
this podcast that we've been trying to
do a lot is you know I sit down
sometimes active gang members police on
the other side and I say you know who's
a guy in your own community that you
really respect who's somebody in that
guy's community that you really respect
who's somebody in your own community
that you think you know kind of just
talks that talks doesn't really walk it
because the truth is we're all human
beings I think that that it's easy to
find these the these lines of respect
you usually laugh at the same we
all care about our kids want our kids to
be happy we you know playing the cards
that were dealt um
and I and I think you said something
else man I have so many
questions for you man but uh you know
the thing that you said that this cop
specifically in Ventura kind of depended
on you guys to keep the police that's
another thing that we sort of keep the
peace excuse me or to
um you know I've lived in Venice for for
a long time and I know you you have a
lot of connections to there too and
um you know one thing that sort of
happened in the last few years is that
uh the sort of transient community and
the homeless Community there's has kind
of run amok and and it's become
extraordinarily dangerous down on the
beach and there's no and you know it's
my understanding from living down there
I had a bunch of guys who were involved
in that Shoreline set down there
and a big thing that that they were
doing is really kind of keeping the
peace you know those those shops down on
the beach you know they were paying
draft to Shoreline and and that was
really you know that made it a much
safer place it's interesting how that
works it is isn't it and and and uh I I
know
I've heard a lot of people about the
roles uh the role that the the angels
have played around here and uh but
that's a real thing I mean sometimes you
need somebody to to come in there and we
had very strict Street rules you know
there was no cooking drugs in Ventura
County uh we didn't want any drive-by
shootings in Ventura County and we had
sit-down meetings with the street gangs
on more than one occasion and it was
interesting the older cops
their attitude was get it done
keep the community safe any way you can
some of the younger cops I had clashes
with them because they said it was none
of our business and we needed to stay
out of it and I said well if we can get
the job done where you can't and the
public is safer for what's the problem
and what is the drive what is the drive
of the Angels you're the president of
the chapter you're you like what to not
have drive-by shootings in the streets
of Ventura or to not be able to not cook
drugs where is that coming from it cuts
with a double-edged sword you know first
of all uh public relations Is everything
you know uh you want the community to
stand behind you because these people
are potentially going to be the jurors
that judge you if you get yourself into
it a jam uh you know that was one of the
things uh and you know we wanted
community support and you know we
had more than one uh
trial you so to speak in the clubhouse
with you know different factions of
Street uh gangs and they were willing to
let us uh get involved you know can that
happen nowadays I don't know I don't
think so probably but uh there was a
time when uh Ventura Hell's Angels had
held heavy sway on the streets but but
is it is there a part of it also like
your kids are there well you care about
yourself you know it's the children uh
uh it's the uh people within the
community trying to run businesses you
know there was a lot of allegations by
one of the district attorneys that you
know we were extorting businesses we
never took a penny from anybody and
there was also allegations that certain
police officers the FBI had made
allegations certain police officers were
on you know my payroll specifically and
that never happened you know that they
were allegations that never could be
proved but you know and back then
an allegation like that made by a law
enforcement uh Department of federal law
enforcement agency held a lot of uh
clout you know people but there's been a
lot of things over the years where you
know now people question uh uh certain
things but uh you know these allegations
back then ruined some of these guys
careers yeah I bet and uh it wasn't fair
and it was because uh certain actions I
had a cop named Butterbean who was uh
just a street cop and the district
attorney wanted him to wire up they
wanted him to come in and uh trick me
with some questions
and uh you know rather than do that now
this is integrity rather than do that
the guy retired what was that behind why
did he do that why did he retire yeah
why did he not why was he adverse to
doing that because I think he was an
honorable man
and it boils down to you were talking
earlier about uh staying on track and
specifics it's just like myself when I
made the decision to leave the club it
took me two years and uh of it's
difficult
to be at the top of your game and walk
away from it because you don't believe
in it anymore and that's basically what
happened you know I wanted to stay true
to myself uh you know I don't uh
I don't want to glorify any of the
actions of what I did Hell's Angels
under my tenure but I don't want to
apologize for it either there you go it
was what it was and it is what it is
there you go and uh you know I stand
behind the things I did there's some
things I did I'm not happy about I some
things in Los Angeles uh maybe if I'd
been a more tenured leader I would have
been stronger in my opposition of things
but you live and learn you know and
sometimes those uh
there's events or catastrophic I mean
I've talked to to Mel a good bit about
the outlaw Wars in Chicago yeah and uh
they came from Chicago the Chicago
Outlaws came here
to kill me what was it what was that
about well I had been negotiating with
uh Taco the international leader of
leaders of the Outlaws and uh
the
we put a moratorium on the violence
there was no more shootings uh we were
trying to negotiate a settlement I went
to him unannounced I just showed up
where'd you go I went uh I was in Terre
Haute Indiana at a prison bike show and
the Hell's Angels and the Outlaws in the
prison put this bike show on together I
went there I was one of the guys from
the street that went because in the
prisons the bike gangs they don't fight
you you don't fight in prison you gotta
you you know that was always my uh
position is we're not fighting in prison
why are we fighting on the street right
where we have everything we want and is
the reason you're not fighting in prison
is because
why do you why is well I think because
of the confinement
I think out of respect uh
if you were fighting on a daily basis
they'd shut the prison yard down I'm
sure the other prison gangs would uh not
be happy with you you know you've got
the Aryan Brotherhood the Mexican Mafia
and the black gorilla family that kind
of runs uh most of them prisons started
here in California and kind of drifted
out and uh one of the things when first
time I went to prison in 1986 guy
castillano from San Diego was a very
powerful leader in the club uh back then
and remained in the club until he passed
away but I said when I got there I was
young you know young guy young leader in
the Hell's Angels and I said who do we
need to worry about in here and he
laughed he goes Nobody and I said what
do you mean nobody because we don't
fight in prison so we don't fight in
prison he goes no he goes there's
Mongols in there Outlaws Banditos and I
said well why are we fighting on the
street and he you know the guy was just
a character he goes you think too much
man just relax and enjoy it so so tell
me about going to see top
well
stairway Harry who was a former
International leader of you got to love
the names yeah yeah uh it was the former
International leader of the Outlaws
he kind of made a political move with me
we were leaving the prison and shook
hands I said hey man it's been a
pleasure meeting you Harry as I've been
hearing about you for years and he goes
hey I got a question for you and I said
okay
and he said and he was very careful how
he structured the question he could
the 50th anniversary is coming up in
Sturgis and he goes how do you feel
about us going he didn't say we're going
or you know he was very structured
because normally because what normally
Outlaws well they didn't go to that room
Hell's Angel bandito run and we shared
it with the Banditos they went there
first and they were gracious enough you
know when we started showing up in
numbers uh they didn't have a problem
with it but he was very careful you know
he said how do you feel about us going
and I said well I don't know I have to
think about it and he goes you know
tacos right up the street from us about
two miles in a motel
and I thought
so I I just went up there by myself
and I got to the motel and I walked up
and I see the Outlaws looking at me
there's about 10 of them outside and
you're wearing it I got my colors on and
I'm you know Hell's Angel George
Christie
and uh they surrounded me and they go
what are you doing man and I go
is Taco here and they go yeah but what
are you doing here I go I want to talk
to Taco
and the one guy that seemed to be in
charge uh
said uh does he know you're coming here
and I go no
and he just goes you're a crazy
he goes go get taco and one
of the guys went in and got him so I'm
standing there I'm surrounded by these
guys and I don't remember this
gentleman's name we're exchanging some
dialogue and taco came around the corner
and like tacos guys stopped he had
complete dominance of those guys and
they all turned to look at Taco and I
looked at him and I said well he's
smiling that's a good sign and we all
kind of started laughing and taco just
shook his head he goes what are you
doing man I said well I came to talk to
you
and the first thing I said to him I said
is look I said I don't know about your
club but our club there are new members
and they don't even know why we're
fighting yeah and he kind of looked at
me and smiled and I said look taco
if you were born in California there's
no doubt you would be a Hell's Angel and
I said if I was born in Chicago I know
I'd be an outlaw I'd go we've got so
much in common man what's the problem
and we just started talking from there
you know next time you see Mel yeah ask
him who uh ask him to tell you about
Spike because Spike's the one that uh
Spike was an ex-army Ranger I was told
killed four or five Hells Angels back
there uh in a matter of months and in
Chicago yeah Chicago area Indiana
Chicago and and he pushed
uh Taco back into the war Taco called me
and told me he said I'm getting a lot of
pressure
and there's a speech that taco gave that
one of the informants eventually flipped
on Taco uh told a reporter and it's I've
got a news article I should send you uh
the I have a book I wrote about it and
I'll get you a copy it's very it's
really interesting but he called me Taco
called me
and it was like just two scooter tramps
talking
one-on-one you know there was no
politics there was no agenda and uh I I
that's the last time I talked to him
maybe the second to the last time I
talked to him and he basically told me
he said hey man I'm getting it's a lot
of political pressure
and he goes how about on your end and I
said you think I'm popular like I'm the
most unpopular guy in the club right now
and I said after you and I appeared on
the cover of that magazine I go man
there's some people hating on me yeah
and we you know we talked we had a very
candid conversation
but uh apparently I didn't impress him
enough because a few weeks later he sent
a hit team out here to kill me oh did he
and uh they showed up here in Ventura
they had a map to my house pictures of
me they had a uh they were driving a car
one guy flew out two guys flew out one
guy drove out how do you know all this
police had to come and tell me that
there had been a murder attempt on my
life that they had foiled they have a
moral obligation they'll come to you and
they'll say we have a moral obligation
to let you know this is what transpired
when you go to that motel that tacos at
and you're going there you know all
those guys are there there's been
whether you've been involved or not been
involved the way we're all involved
you're a Hell's Angel you're involved
exactly you're an outlaw you're involved
in one way or the other there have been
many people who have been killed and
killed because of this war between these
two clubs and you're going over there by
yourself right and there's there's what
15 20 30 guys there you know probably at
least 18 15. whatever it is uh when
you're pulling in there you're armed
with the fact that you're going there to
to to make peace to be like hey man I'm
just looking at you man-to-man what is
that right like what's your mindset
going on but I was my position was
and I'm going to say something I'm going
to comment on it after this statement my
position was I was doing the right thing
and I was doing it for the benefit of
the Hell's Angels The Outlaws The Outlaw
community at large and and the people uh
around us yeah and uh I uh
I also felt Invincible John
do you ever have that feeling I do when
I was young man I just felt invincible
and I thought nothing could stop me and
uh
I uh but can I ask you about that I mean
like is is that I guess where I'm going
is is that invincibility was that
something that you just blanket you just
had with you all the time or was that in
certain situations depending upon your
intentionality or depending on where
your heart was at
I felt like I was invincible at all
times and I I'm not my ego if you know I
get it I just the way I felt I felt like
nothing could stop me I felt I had right
on my side and uh you know
as you get older you learn right doesn't
always win that's right but you know if
you know you you look at the history of
these people that took on different uh
cultures different uh Empires and
whatnot you know you'll get Hannibal you
know there's no wave is going to beat
the the Romans but uh he had to give it
a try would you feel that way even in
the face of of real violence I mean I
know you've you've you you've you've
been involved in real violence the
clubhouse been bombed twice uh uh you
know and that's not the only violence
you know like false charges from law
enforcement indictments I had a 59 count
State racketeering indictment once I
spent a year in solitary confinement you
know but through and through all that
that that that that that feeling of
invincibility remained no it it starts
getting shipped away sure as you get
older and I don't know if you're if you
get more sensible
uh are if
as the you know I'm 75 now you know uh I
still try to keep up with my former self
but it's not easy how do you do that
well you know I get up every morning I
go walk uh five miles uh you know I come
home try to eat uh eat right then you
know I have another exercise program in
the afternoon you know I do my aerobic
stuff on the treadmill and do a little
bit of martial arts stuff and very very
light weights and stretching and uh it
matters that to me that was like money
in the bank for my future there you go
and uh that's what I suggest to people
you know you know did a lot of partying
when I was younger but I always knew
the party had to come to an end Sunday
morning the party was over for me
unfortunately a lot of my brothers uh
people that are not here anymore
in fact uh they're just about all gone
they didn't uh Pace themselves if you
will this feeling of invincibility that
you're talking about too I I would
imagine you know you know going in and
you know putting your patch down and
saying I'm out and then you know the
difference I I was uh can you just sort
of explain you know I had
been building up to it building up to it
I didn't discuss it with anybody nobody
absolute uh
solo uh decision
my son was walking up to the door in the
clubhouse I'm I can remember and I I
said I need to talk to you soon and I
put my arm around him and we walked up
the street
and uh I said I'm hanging it up tonight
how old was he
probably
the late 20s and was he was he a member
yes he was a member and I said I'm
hanging it up tonight he goes what and I
go look man
I said I've come to terms of a lot of
things and I said this is not the club I
joined and I said I just I can't do it
anymore and I said you know people
aren't sharing my vision I go uh you
know
when you are a leader you share your
vision with the people behind you and
when they no longer share that Vision
you know maybe you're not a leader
anymore and I said it's time for me to
reevaluate where I'm heading in this
journey I'm on and uh
my mind's made up I'm gonna I'm gonna
hang it up so I went in where was he at
with that
he just
kissed me and said you know hugged me
and said okay dad you know best I know
you know what you need to do for
yourself and he walked in there and uh I
uh
now stood up and announced to the club
what I was doing initially they thought
that I was stepping down as president
and I said no no that's not what this is
I said I'm I'm stepping down and I you
know I took my patch off and I folded it
like a flag
and uh
I looked around the room and I didn't
see anybody I wanted to hand it to you
know I wanted to exclude my son I didn't
think
you know he should be part of that
decision and I laid it on the corner of
the table and uh I said vanities got
anything to say say it now
and nobody said anything it was very sad
very emotional and I'll tell you the
walk
from my chair I always sat in a chair
against the back wall I was the
president's chair
of
the walk from that chair to the door the
threshold of the door to let me out was
the longest walk I ever took in my life
what's going through your mind your
heart just thinking man there's no
turning back now George you know you
made this decision you got to live with
it and uh
what does that entail like what is it in
that in that moment what did you think
living with it entailed
I thought that uh foolishly I thought
that I would uh be able to uh go about
my business uh
wasn't sure John
about a week and a half I got a phone
call uh from uh the new uh president of
the charter and he said you know we've
been doing a lot of thinking and we've
decided to change our status you're now
out bad you can have absolutely no
contact uh
with any club members and they can't
contact you in any way and I said
well you know I said it's kind of
interesting I said at least the
government
always gave me the opportunity to uh
answer to the charges you guys aren't
even going to give me the opportunity
and he basically said that's not the one
that's not the way Sunny wants it and
sunny and I had been at odds and uh I
despite that you know I I respected the
man till the end I didn't agree with him
what was the Crux of your disagreement
political decisions
I guess the biggest disagreement was
Sunny felt there were two sets of rules
rules for the entitled uh members and
then you had your general membership can
you be a little bit more specific like
what what are those different rules like
what like he did what he wanted
[Laughter]
really John I can't make it any more
clearer than that I mean uh
I'm working on a new book and uh
defining the differences in our
leadership styles it's not a uh I'm not
slinging mud at him uh you know I got a
phone call
maybe this is going to explain a little
bit I got a phone call the night before
he died you know I was not allowed to
have any contact with any club members
but I have had since I've been gone
people write me and call me and I
certainly keep it in confidence I don't
want to get them in trouble because it
was you know a kick out of the club if
you got caught communicating with me
and uh
I think he said
person on the other hand you know he's
basically said you recognize with his
voice and I said yeah and I we kind of
have bantered back and forth I teased
him uh I said yeah it's my Rabbi and uh
you know we just went back and forth and
joking he said I got something to tell
you and I said what's that because if
you're going to reconcile with Ralph
that's what we you know it's a close
circle of friends call him so if you're
going to reconcile with route he better
do it because he's not going to last
much longer and I you know I stayed up
the rest of that night and uh drinking
coffee and thinking and uh
I decided against calling him because
and this was kind of a selfish decision
I figured that if I called him we got an
argument and he passed away uh during
the the discussion I'd get the blame for
killing him yeah yeah yeah so I'd be a
little facetious but there's also some
some truth of what I'm saying so I you
know I uh I decided against it and I
thought
you know it's interesting when I when I
did the outlaw Chronicles
the Dead
days and days you know what it's like to
film you know you do it you do it you do
it and then they take the best stuff and
they saved the uh last episode of The
Sixth episode you know sunny and myself
for last and it was
really profound the producer of that
show who have a lot of respect for
uh when the when the
day was over with
he just looked at me and he goes you
still love that guy don't you you
respect him and uh he goes man he goes
you could have thrashed him and he goes
and I said there's no reason to thrash
him I go what he did was what he did
what I did was what I did we were two
different leaders to do different styles
but the guy's an icon you know I mean
Sonny Barger man you know I was hearing
about him in in school you know in high
school and the guys I you know I hung
out with I hung out with a young Outlaw
bike club called the question marks who
were endorsed by the Hell's Angels I
mean he was a living legend there's no
doubt about it when you're in that room
and you give the guys that that speech
and you decide to leave the patch on the
table
do you love the guys in that room sure
yeah there's
I dream about those guys John I mean I
had some profound dreams I haven't found
dreams anyways I always have my whole
life but uh
you know I had dreams of the older guys
that were had passed on to the other
side you know
call me I can't believe you did it man
and then I would have young guys in the
dreams coming to me asking me questions
and I go I I can't give you the answers
I'm not in the club anymore you know you
know I would wake up and uh you know
sometimes I wake up violently you know a
very profound intense dreams I don't
have them like I did but I you know I
still have uh I still have those dreams
when you talk about uh like the 80s and
and being in that La chapter and the the
war with them okay then the 70s can you
just uh I know this is something I know
you don't want to do it uh you know it's
something that's been sort of
romanticized and people but like what
you know just kind of like walk me
through what that was like be being in
well first thing I want to I want to
qualify by saying this
anybody that thinks
war is romantic
whatever type of War they've never been
in a war exactly because it's not
romantic it's uh it's stressful uh you
don't know uh when it's Gonna Come
uh you know when you declare war on
somebody whether it be on a large basis
as if we're a country going into another
country uh because we don't like their
culture whatever it may be you know uh
uh you
you get in the situations uh that uh
you never dreamed you would be you know
I uh made some I was just a member
initially during When The War started
and uh
six months into the war you know there
was already six murders in as many
months uh the leader of the charter down
there got murdered it was described as
an in-house cleaning by law enforcement
uh you know I've written about it
extensively and you know two of my books
uh
but I became vice president you know I
came in in the middle of a conflict and
I had to try to shift the direction of
what we were doing and what was the
reason for you rising up the way that
you did
old man John who was the leader of
after the
president that took his place John had
been the leader down there old man John
was kind of a legend he was an old man
when uh I was in my 20s you know and uh
I got some pictures I'll send of you if
he's a character he had a really great
picture of him with
two pairs of glasses on he's an old
school dude he had regular
like government issue glasses and he
didn't want to have him he'd want to
spend the money to have them buy Focus
yeah so he put no he what he did is he
put sunglasses over his regular glasses
because he didn't want to pay for the
tent you know it's too much money I
might waste my money yeah I just put a
pair of glasses over yeah yeah and I got
this great picture of him looking at his
motorcycle with double glasses on and I
posted sometimes on social media and uh
you know people like young guys write me
and they go who is this guy man you know
he don't care what he looks like and I
go no man John didn't care about much
yeah yeah and uh so you know
I guess you know he mentored me you know
and it gave me a lot of Sway and he saw
something in me you got to real and I
just got out of the Marines worked for
the Department of Defense uh I had a
structured background and John was
military a former military World War II
and uh he just put me under his wing and
uh when when the war started with the
Mongols John was very disappointed
it was very
convoluted a lot of detail to it but in
a nutshell
uh the war started he wasn't happy he
stepped down was there a specific yeah
we were uh it had been brewing between
us and the Mongols and uh how so well
first of all there was a rumor on the
street that the Mongols started uh
because we wouldn't allowing Hispanics
in our club which was a complete lie
David Ortega who I met in 1966 and we
were best friends until he passed away
you know he was in the question marks
and he was in the Hell's Angels and you
know he was uh
Mexican-American you know Johnny Angel
from Oakland you know he was a Mexican I
could go fat Ray I could go on and on
and on so it wasn't true but you know
that
that Vibe was there and uh
probably
the oldest reason in the world was that
one of the Hell's Angels EX
wife was now living with a Mongol
and we went to a swap meet there was
nine of us it was about 40 to 60 Mongols
and
we met them by accident by accident and
where was the swap meet it was in Santa
Ana and it was the that's a crazy place
to run into somebody yeah so the the I
think it might have been the Great
Western exhibit or something so this all
happened to be there at the same time
same time you know so I was there uh
I got a great story too I was there and
uh
the member whose wife had run off with
the Mongol their eyes met and I looked
at both of them and I knew it was on you
know because I knew the history this guy
was my best friend you know the Hell's
Angels and uh
I uh looked at him looked at uh this guy
Bud who was now living with us and you
know my friend just caught this guy you
could just you know what a sock a
perfect punch sounds like just echoed in
there and uh
it was on you know we got in a circle
and uh they were surrounding us and we
were fighting everyone's fighting
everybody yeah just I mean the Hell's
Angels and the Mongols are frightened
and
Jesse who later became my vice president
in Los Angeles when I took over the club
down there and later became a Hell's
Angel here in Ventura
fell down this big Mongol hit him and he
fell down and he I kind of looked out of
the corner of my eye and
he had his arms spread out and I
there was a motor sprocket gear there
and motor sprockets are about this big
with spikes on it and a hole in the
center he hooked it on his hand he
jumped up and he just started hacking
people and there was blood and flesh
flying and people screaming and you know
everybody fighting and in the middle of
all this
imagine a young
scared police officer uniform police
officer there was one of Santa Ana
police officer one
one uniform for the whole event you know
this is
1976 or 77. so one uniformed officer and
he comes in and he's got his revolver
drawn now he's only got six shots he's
got a revolver you know service revolver
and he's yelling at everybody and we're
all looking at each other
and this gun looks about this big of
course did he put it did he put a stop
to it first yeah yeah yeah it stopped
yeah everybody stopped and so the when
they when we stopped the Mongols broke
and I'm not saying they broke and ran
because they were scared because these
guys weren't scared uh it they stopped
they broke and ran we broke and ran and
so everybody's getting away you know and
uh I uh I ran out and there was a Mongol
the fight had stopped now and there was
a Mongol and he goes what the hell's
going on he's like yelling at me and
there's like the cops started kind of
there was more cops like starting to
come around I don't know if they were
outside or what that happened so fast
and I said you don't know what's going
on you know this I'm young and I'm a
Hell's Angel and I'm in my 20s and I
think I'm cool and I go you know what's
going on he goes no what's going on and
I go this is what's going on and I
smacked him and we started fighting and
the cops started beating on us both of
us with the club and the same slaves who
were like I you know I came that close
to becoming a saint so rather than a
Hell's Angel I was so close with those
guys
they got around the cop and they said
don't hit that Hell's Angel they're
gonna hit the Mongol and so the cops for
whatever reason turned and started his
Mongol the same slaves grabbed me and
these guys were all like six one six two
big dudes and uh carried me out of there
the rest of the Hell's Angels were there
there was like six of us on bikes it was
like nine of us there and we were all
started laughing hysterically and uh we
jumped on our bikes kicked our bikes
over you know no electric starters back
then kicked our bikes over and we ran
out of that place man I felt like I was
in the James gang we just robbed a bank
we're laughing and uh so we get back to
the clubhouse in Glendale
and old man John's already heard about
the fight and old man John 6 4
big hands and he always had a cigar in
his mouth and it was always half smoked
and he always chomped on it when he was
talking to bounce up and down and what
the hell is going on out there and he
takes it out of his mouth and we're
going well John uh got in a fight you
know I know you got a goddamn fight you
know what he's going on and on and uh
but he didn't what he was mad at you
never guess what he was mad at John that
those guys the Mongols had the nerve to
lay a hand on us he wasn't mad at us we
started the fight but he wasn't mad at
us he was mad because they laid a hand
on us and so he ran in the house
comes out with a pump shotgun he had
this old Ford Mustang I don't know what
year it was it was an old one faded
paint you know uh it was a rag top I
remember the top being all you know just
and he opened the trunk up and he's
smoking on the cigar and he throws a
shotgun and he tells
who was going to become the guy that has
eventually murdered who's going to
become the new Hells Angel president in
Los Angeles because you go with me and
uh
why'd he pick him I don't know uh I'll
tell you another thing John used to tell
me and uh it would make a lot of sense
to you I didn't ask John because John
told me one time because you want to
last in this business quit asking
questions I said okay fair enough and so
I didn't ask questions but I said I did
confront him I said hey John don't you
think it'd be better to let them Brew on
the fight
and no wonder what's going to be next
and then we can petition you know for a
sit down because what I mean John's idea
was just goes out and he told me you
know what he told me what
new guy get your ass in the clubhouse I
went back in the clubhouse and he took
off with Ray and you know Jesse and I
were uh in the clubhouse Jesse you know
was the guy with the the motor sprocket
you know we just sat in there all night
you know waiting for John then John we
see the headlights rolling in the
driveway and he had resolved it but uh
you know I felt
and I respectfully told him uh alone I
never questioned him in front of anybody
I said man I think it would have been
smarter from a military standpoint to
wait and let them Brew on what was going
to come next and then petition them
you know John John didn't care you know
John didn't care about anything you know
all John cared about was us we were his
family and uh you know he was a real old
school guy you know he'd tell you
one time he took me to a fight with
another bike club I didn't even know you
know you didn't ask back then what we
were doing told me to get on my bike
and me adjusting a couple other guys who
got on our bikes and you know we went
over to this other motorcycle clubs
Clubhouse and uh John asked for somebody
in the the guy came up John clocked him
knock I'm you know just incredible power
uh knocked the guy down and he just
don't ever disrespect me again and got
on the bike so we wrote off you know I
mean that's the kind of that John
would do right and you know I said John
uh what are we going to do now you know
and uh
a couple of weeks later I don't know if
I hope and I've never really reflect on
it until now I just had this Epiphany I
hope what I said to him didn't cause him
to uh
step down because that that's I
respected him you know wholeheartedly
and I I was just giving him some input
what I thought he stepped down Ray took
over within two weeks uh you know there
was a
machine gunnings on the freeway two
Mongols got killed jingles and red bill
red bedroom machine guns off their bikes
uh the frame up motorcycle shop uh Tire
stuff with dynamite uh was taken there
uh it detonated killed two guys uh
you know it's just brutal real quick can
you imagine shooting machine guns in
downtown no way I mean and bombing
businesses in downtown L.A and I think
there's probably this misconception you
know to to to the citizens you know I
think there's this misconception that
the reason why these you know I know
there's that that thing that happened in
Laughlin or or you know there's that
these wars are over because these are
you know criminal Enterprises they're
fighting over Turf because they want to
run guns or so this is ego literally one
guy was sleeping with another guy's
ex-wife you know we talked about the
Outlaws earlier you know what that fight
was about would that started greased
lightning who uh was an outlaw and Sandy
Alexander who was leader of the uh
Hell's Angels uh in New York City
formerly both members of the alien
motorcycle club they were brothers at
one time
uh greased lightning came to visit Sandy
he wasn't there Colette Sandy's wife
said uh he raped her and uh Sandy was a
professional boxer
uh greased lightning shows back up in
New York Sandy beats him up he goes back
to uh The Outlaws and said I got jumped
by the whole Charter because he got beat
so bad you know Sandy uh just really put
it on he's a boxer you know professional
boxer
so uh two motor two members from uh the
East Coast go down to Florida to uh get
an ex-member
to cover his tattoo Who's down there
selling narcotics and posing as a Hell's
Angel that's another whole story we
could talk about they go down there
while they're down there the Outlaws
here they're in town and they invite
them to the clubhouse
they are told by Sandy don't go to the
clubhouse well they go to the clubhouse
and uh
one of the leaders uh decides they're
going to take retribution for grease
lightning and uh they take them down on
the rock quarry and shoot them both in
the back of the head and the Hells Angel
exhales Angel who's still impersonating
uh the Hell's Angels taking down the
rock quarry chain them up throw them in
there and then a few weeks later one of
the guys uh name uh club name was
Riverboat and uh you know the
started kind of like a little Legend
within the club that you know Riverboat
came to the surface as well he came to
the service and and uh we had been
calling Outlaws hey what happened to
these guys and they said we don't know
man they were here and they left we knew
they were at their Clubhouse because
Sandy had talked to him told him not to
go that fight was over a woman yeah so
we've got two conflicts that are still
on going to this day wow and they're
both about egos hurt feelings and
whatnot it's not about territory you
know
people that are selling narcotics and
somebody else's territory you're not
going to know they're there they're
going to come in under the stealth of
Darkness or whatever it may be seller
Wares and get the hell out yeah right
it's it's usually they're not doing it
brazenly in public
you know that's a good way to get busted
yeah and uh you know they go into these
uh areas in the clandestine mode you
know I mean these fights were over Egos
and territory like don't come in our
territory not because it has anything to
do with narcotics right so don't come in
our territory and you know uh I didn't
say it earlier I wanted to allude to it
earlier but you know
to Be an Effective Peacemaker you have
to be willing to go to war yeah I really
did learn that you know I really wanted
to ask you um you know George horn give
me give me just one second somebody piss
my pants all right give me give me just
one second I apologize I got all day
okay
I got that I got that jailhouse
discipline man I can I don't know where
you want to pick it up at is after Taco
put the hit on me I went to Chicago and
confronted those guys uh
at a meeting and what does that entail
you getting on a plane yeah I got on a
Plane by yourself uh I took one guy with
me who do you take with you I took Josh
with me a young guy and why you take
Josh
because I
figured he'd be right there he was he
was 25 24 and he reminded me of myself
uh you know he thought he was invincible
and you know the sad thing about Josh he
got killed uh later you know unsolved
uh which is a that story it's a story in
itself
but uh Josh and I after I found out
man I was smoking John you know that uh
and you can look this up on the Internet
it's uh United States of America versus
Harry Taco Bowman and it's got all the
details of uh you know they were going
to either kill Sonny or me and they
decided to kill me
and uh for whatever reason I don't know
I didn't I didn't ask Taco I did talk to
Taco
after uh the Murray contract which is
also another funny story but I'll tell
you about I'll I don't know if I'm
getting out of sync you're perfect so
you go you go to it so I get on a plane
I go back to Chicago
we're gonna have a sit down with the
Outlaws because we're trying to rein
tacos now in jail
what year is this roughly late 90s tacos
are now in jail he was on the FBI's he
might have been number one he was on the
top 10 most wanted fugitives
so I go back there and uh and you knew
he was in Chicago I knew he was that he
had been picked up
and he's from Chicago I knew that was
the Chicago Outlaws and the taco had
ordered my murder they had chose to kill
me rather than Sonny
so I hear there's a meeting with the
Outlaws back east
so I tell my Charter I'm going you know
Josh because I'm going with you man so
we get on the plane we go back there
and we go to the meeting and uh
there's Hells Angels there and there's
uh
Outlaws there and we're sitting across
the table from each other and
I said
you know I raise my hand I said I want
to say something
and then I'm going to leave
and
I don't I'm usually very protocol and I
my guys knew like oh George is pissed
about something
and so I went into it I said I know
about the hit I know the police came and
they told me
and I said you know what you do this
during peace talks you don't even call
off the peace talks
and uh you just come after me
you're in my town with a map pictures of
me and a silenced equipped handgun
and I go I want to tell you guys
something now I said I'll respect
whatever
my club decides in this room today I
will respect
but there's a point and I said this is
what I'm telling you I said if you ever
come back to Ventura again without an
invitation a personal invitation from me
I said I will find out who ordered it
and who participated and I said I will
come into the house I said I'll kill
everybody in the house your wife your
children your dog Your Cat And I said on
my way out I'm going to over feed your
fish you know and this might what you
just shared you know kind of leads me
into it just talk about a little bit
look I asked you a few minutes and you
said you did and you said before I had
to um before I almost pissed my
pantyhose that that that uh you said
that you know in order to
to keep peace Be an Effective Peacemaker
you have to be capable of violence and
willing to go there and I I believe that
with all my heart I also believe like
like yourself and so many of the folks
that we've talked to that have
been on both sides of the law in their
life I really believe that folks that
have really been down in the valley
people that are both capable of and have
sort of committed uh some of the most
heinous acts are also capable of doing
the most beautiful and godly work
they're able to lift other people it's
interesting it's crazy and I I we keep
kind of coming back to that and I think
there's something
to the extent unless you've been down
there you're not going to be able to
take a hand from someone to be lifted
out of that unless they've been down
there too you know I'll tell you
something I I in 2000
one I got indicted on that 59 count
racketeering charge and I I spent a year
uh in isolation and
and top of isolation
they have they put you in the hole and I
had
I've got my chicken dinner uh
you know shoved through the slot and
myself I've never got out of my cell in
the isolation unit
and uh I have a bridge on one side of my
mouth and they don't allow you any
much for hygienic stuff
and I kept a bone
out of the chicken's leg it was very
long and you know the long skinny bone
that's kind of hooked and I would use it
to clean my bridge after
my meal I had it hidden in my room in
the cell and they came in there shook my
room down
and uh
they found they found the bone and uh as
crazy as it sounds they had a trial
the prison officials had a trial and I
had to go to the trial and uh they set
the bone that's the evidence they put
the bone down and
they said were you going to try to put
somebody's eye out with this bone and I
you know I was laughing I said
and I go
no I said I just to clean my bridge you
know and they didn't believe me of
course and they said no we think that
you saved that you were going to put one
of the guards eyes out and uh
kind of looking at him and there's a
pencil but I mean I picked a pencil up
and I go now this is something I can put
somebody's eye out with at all you know
they got all pissed off so they said
okay now we're going to sentence you
to the whole I was in isolation but now
I'm going to the whole
and we're putting you on a disciplinary
diet they don't do it anymore they
enough Roots were violent where they
stopped it the disciplinary diet is they
feed you in the morning and they feed
you at night you get two pieces of bread
you get a protein loaf
which is just enough calories to sustain
you uh you know so you you know you
don't uh
starve to death if you're on it you know
for any length of time and you get two
glasses of water or one glass of water
you can't remember and if one of the
cool guards was there he'd slip a milk
into you so you could get some more
protein and because there are cool
guards down there of course you don't
get
no mail you don't get no newspapers
magazines any of that stuff but they
leave
a Bible
there's a Bible in there and uh
so I started reading the Bible I've read
the Bible as a my parents are Greek
Orthodox my mom was very religious
my mom and my aunt uh I uh
got some funny stories about my family
too as Greeks but uh
I started reading the Bible man and you
know
that's where I I had already been on
this path of peace and whatnot but
some pretty heavy duty stories in the
Bible you know I just I Revisited them
all you know and I read the whole Bible
and uh
I think
you really get some insight into history
of violence in the Bible yeah you know
and you know I I truly mean that you
know to Be an Effective Peacemaker you
have to be willing to go to war and I
imagine that it like in most I mean look
whether you're talking about your Peewee
tackle football team whether you're
talking about a a unit in the Marine
Corps you're talking about a a plain
close police unit or you're talking
about a motorcycle club you know you get
a group of men together and
whether you like it or not everyone is
sort of judged to some extent of what
your willingness and your ability to to
to to engage how far will you take it
and it's and and you know it's it's it's
sort of been my experience with the
different people that I've had the
pleasure of getting close with that in
any organization something Mel talks
about all the time Mel always says you
know man it's these one percenters these
motorcycle guy guys but it's only one
percent of the one percenters that are
actually they're actually get out there
that's what he always says and I don't
know maybe you can back up but everybody
I've talked to it says that Mel is
actually that that guy yeah sure and you
know there was a handful of uh
you know people I get people right I
have like there's a picture floating
around the internet with me with a
filthy few badge on you know and I'm not
going to get into specifics you know you
can use your imagination What does it
mean and that was a group within the
club it was a group of a small group of
you guys that are within the club and I
heard that that about yourself as well
and I I guess what I'm asking is not
like how far are you willing to take it
is there a line you're willing to cross
but I I
I guess you know like when you say that
one guy picked up the the the the spigot
ranch or whatever the motorcycle motor
sprocket you saw I don't know but
like when he picked that up you
I guess can you just talk about the
currency of violence in in that world
and I'll tell you the interesting thing
about and I left a portion out not
intentionally I just my mind uh you know
I'm uh having a lot of fun here and I'm
trying to get as much as I can and
but when he caught up
and he ripped that across the guy that
knocked him down was waiting for him you
know when he got up and Jesse bounced up
and he ripped that motor sprocket across
his cheek
and that guy howled it was a primal
scream and uh
I looked at Jesse he was smiling yeah
you know I mean he was willing to take
it uh however and you know the uh you
know you live by the sword Die By The
Sword just he was murdered you know
ultimately and you know it's unsolved uh
Josh was murdered uh and it's remains
unsolved you know I could go on and on
and on of all these individuals uh
but is that true like kind of Acro
across the board as far as you know were
there members that you felt like were
adverse of ions were there members that
you felt like deep down were scared of
it and yeah yeah I think members that
were scared look yeah some guys wear the
jacket and wear the patch and and we're
walking the walk that's right that's
right you know but does everybody know
it does everybody know what things guys
are yeah it doesn't take long you know
it's interesting Big Al who was original
filthy few member uh in 19 late 70s uh
the Bay Area guys got indicted for
racketeering and uh I don't know if you
know who the U.S attorney was on that
case it was Mueller yeah I heard that it
was Mueller yeah and uh
so they pull we always pull the jurors
after the trial and uh so the lawyers
pull the jurors and uh I don't know if
you know who Tony Sarah is Tony Sarah is
a very famous Civil Rights and criminal
lawyer of the Bay Area I've used him
personally and uh you guys incredible
but you know they pull the juror
uh jury afterwards and uh
they said the jurors said
they didn't believe any Witnesses they
didn't believe any FBI agents they
didn't believe any paid informants and
they didn't believe any Hells Angels
with the exception of Big Al and they
said Big Al not only walks the walk not
only talks to talk he walks the walk and
what Big Al said to him is they had
pictures of letters that Big Al had been
sending home
and uh
in these letters said he had millions of
dollars hidden uh diamonds rubies and it
was going to all be hers when he got
home are you sending it to his lady yeah
I sent it to his ladies so the U.S
attorney I don't know if it was Mueller
personally I wasn't there on this
particular uh day but uh he said I've
got a letter here uh Mr Perryman that
states and he's showing the jury uh this
letter about he said the million dollars
in the rubies and the Diamonds and it's
all hers surprised he's trying to keep
his old lady that's what he said he says
explain that to me anything he was and
Albert's all Albert's the most joyous
guy in the world he looks at the jury
and he goes obviously this
never been in prison he goes what do you
think I'm going to tell her I'm
broke yeah you can't take her on date
night and the jury man they just go yeah
yeah Albert yeah that makes sense yeah
yeah it speaks the truth yeah he speaks
the truth yeah yeah and what about what
what about like those guys I mean
because there's also a big thing I
imagine
um you know there's a I'm not gonna name
any names but there have been people you
know now that the show that this this
podcast show is kind of getting out
there a bit a lot of people call us to
be honest oh really and there's uh and
there's um there's a couple guys who
reached out who said they're Hell's
Angels and they know this and that and
and
um you know they were there you know and
and you know I I always call Mel and and
and you know Mel's like nah man those
those guys aren't real you know and and
is that a real thing like I mean it's a
it's a you know it's a shame and uh when
I did the uh Outlaw Chronicles
of and I I think you might have I don't
think I said uh while we were talking
together I think I mentioned it when you
went out uh Sonny threatened to sue me
uh uh it's gonna stop the get her
injunction and stop it and uh so they
vetted everything I said uh
and
everything I said on the History Channel
was vetted and but there's a lot of guys
out there you know talking a lot of
stuff I see stuff on social media you
know I don't know who these guys are you
know and sometimes they'll I get
derogatory remarks uh made to me by
people uh and uh you know my response to
them is you know I'm creating a
historical record this is my story I'd
rather talk about myself than have a
hundred years from now somebody you know
yeah well we found out George wore
dresses on the on Friday night you know
but but you know what I'm saying I know
exactly what you're saying but I guess
you know it's one thing that you know
to write something down you know in the
safety of your home behind your computer
but our our guys like rolling around
with patches on I mean our guys rolling
around with you know I I
I you know there are some active members
you know I've had no issues with them I
was in Spain for three years I ran into
the Hell's Angels there I partied with
the Banditos and uh the unknowns and
other one percent Club there uh uh like
I said I ran into the Hell's Angels uh
they uh
they didn't uh
disrespect me uh they really didn't
acknowledge me I got a a nod from one of
them and I was approached by one young
member on his own like I used to get up
every morning you know 4 30 go for a
walk in Spain man it's just incredible
to walk those streets and those alleys
and whatnot and when you go out at 5 30
in the morning the bars are just closing
and everybody's on the streets and it's
it's like a festival and I saw this big
guy
coming at me
and I was thinking okay and uh you know
I'm always on guard and uh he points at
me he goes George Christie right
and I said yeah and then he told me who
he was I'm not going to say who he was
because he said some really Cavalier
things I
he says can I take a picture with you
you think that's a good idea and uh he
goes I'm from Spain he goes I don't take
my orders from Sonny Barger and I said
whatever you want to do man you know he
took some pictures of me and that you
know that's the way I was treated over
there you know you know I've seen some
Ventura Hells Angels here and you know
they don't acknowledge me and I don't
acknowledge them and uh I uh I don't try
to make myself big and get in their
space and I hope that they would show me
the same respect back
but you know but you're who you are yeah
you're who you are doesn't change I mean
John you you didn't decide to go move to
Kansas no I stayed right here I did and
uh there was a rumor for a while that
you know I had been run out of town
that's where I went to Spain it's kind
of hard to explain for the people that
started that rumor and now that I'm back
right uh that you guys negotiated a
piece that is an inconvenience yeah it
is an inconvenience for the story so you
need to be careful what you say to
people sure and I've I'm like I'm
laughing at which because you get it
yeah yeah it's like they people can talk
a lot of that's right but uh they
should be ready to back it up but that's
right you know I you know look the war
in L.A
was just
it was devastating on everybody the
the victims the victims families
uh the extended victims of the people
who went to prison for the crimes they
committed it affected their families you
know
people
go do time in prison
from to me the real victims are the
family like you know I'm a hard ass I
you know they sent me to Texas I spent a
year in Texas with the Banditos uh
I didn't suffer my family when you were
locked up yeah my family suffered yeah I
did that and uh it not only
once they get you in their clutches like
you get you're on federal paper you call
it you know like Pearl or probation
whatever you want to call it they don't
have parole or probation it's they call
it probation now but it's it's
essentially parole
I did the History Channel uh the
probation parole department wanted to
take all my money
uh the money that I got for uh they said
well you can't you know you can't profit
off your criminal past
and uh I said would you rather have me
out robbing a bank
I said there's a lot of nice branches
around here you know I was being a smart
ass you know and uh you know I got a big
dialogue with them
and
I think this is important to say I'm
getting off the track again but
uh
I sat and then all they harped on was
the money they wonder how much money I
was making how much was I going to give
to them because I had a fine imposed on
me by the court
and uh
you know I said you know
I said I'm kind of ashamed of you people
I go I'm paying for you to watch me
through my taxes that's right
and I say I've been back now four months
I said I think I've done wonders man I
got a book deal I got a TV show Brewing
and you haven't asked me once how am I
re-entry to society is going do you even
give a all you care about is the
money and what I'm doing and is it
legitimate uh I said what about the
re-entry into society as a ex-convict
I'm a multiple felon I'm almost 70 years
old and I'm a multiple felon what the
hell am I supposed to do with my life
you know
and I'm not crying I'm just telling you
there's a lot of obstacles out there and
I think the families uh it makes it
tough on the families I'm working with
uh a kid now you know his mom and dad
uh I wound up trying to Mentor this guy
you know he's in trouble and you know
his biggest problem is
he doesn't see himself
as a criminal he sees himself as a
victim you know I I did a lot of I do
Consulting for lawyers
and uh I know a lot about the strategy
in courtrooms uh uh a lot of lawyers
will refer to me and talk to me I you
know I work as a
witness uh and whatnot for the defense
and
I had a client who had embezzled
a bunch of money from Sony movie he was
a director he embezzled a bunch of money
from Sony and uh
Sony didn't want to come after him
because they were afraid the way the
payroll system was set up they could be
deceived by other people they were
trying to keep it on the down low
and he called me one day and he was
almost in tears and uh
he said to me it's just profound
I go what's the matter man you really
sat down he goes I am George because
they're treating me like a criminal
and I said my friend yeah you are a
criminal welcome welcome aboard my
friend I'm also a little bit interested
you know I I understand what you're
talking about
um
about anybody who sort of romanticizes
War anybody you know has never been been
in it and I I think that's true of
violence in general and and I think uh
you know when I look at
um I imagine during those days when you
were in La uh you know if you're riding
around you know when the Hell's Angels
ride around I mean it's a pretty big
presence up here so like you see him you
know I mean it's a they they make
themselves known loud motorcycles and
Loud colors you know very visual very
visual right so I imagine every day
you're riding around during a war
there's Target on your back and that
that's is that something that you carry
with you palpably every moment yeah
absolutely you know and this is the
thing John I like I'm working on this
new book and I just I put you know we
were fighting Wars on two fronts in
Southern California we were fighting the
Mongols but we were fighting law
enforcement law enforcement as well and
you know it's like
it's one thing to go to a uh occupied
country
you know as long as you follow the rules
somewhat
you're not going to have a problem uh
you know you're not going to get
court-martialed unless you do something
really off the wall
but you figure you're on the street
doing the same things you would do in a
award Zone but you know you're not a
hero man to law enforcement to society
you're you're a criminal that's right
and uh uh it becomes very precarious you
know but what was it what was the during
those days in L.A what were the what
were some great like what are some great
memories what are what are your Fondest
Memories what what what was I mean I
imagine also there's another side to it
there's a reason why you guys it's it's
not an easy thing to be a part of look
right
when I got voted in the club now I got
voted in the club December 26th how do
you get voted in well someone brings you
up your sponsor my sponsor happened to
be old man John uh uh when he brings you
up they go around the room and they vote
and uh
I uh this is in my stage play of
the you know we were standing around
this fire was December 26 it was you
know it can get cold in uh Los Angeles
not like the East but we were standing
around a 50 Barrel drum you know wood in
it and we're staying warm and the door
opened and
everybody looked at the door and uh the
old man stepped out
you know fill the door you know all of a
sudden the door was black because you
know and you know I still remember to
this day Christy get your ass in here
and I man I ran I looked at everybody
like you know maybe this is it you know
and I ran in there and I got in there
and uh
The Room everybody was against the walls
the Hell's Angels in there and they were
all
measuring me watching me
and uh so John
you know said to me uh well
are you ready
and uh you know I couldn't even get the
words out you know I was I was like
shaking my head and he finally said well
say something you know and I go yeah
John I'm ready and he goes you know what
this means right
and I said yeah I know what it means and
John he says you don't know nothing
and uh he goes we're your new family he
goes we come first
you understand that don't you
I said yes and I you know I looked
around the room and just everybody was
standing there and
John looked at Paul Paul uh we had two
guys in Los Angeles small Paul and Tall
Paul everybody's got handles you know
and uh tall Paul who wasn't really tall
uh uh taller yeah he was taller than
small though he took his patch and he
folded it up and he threw it at me and I
caught it
and
I opened it up and I outstretched my
arms and I looked at it and it looked
like that death head the emblem on the
back was staring at me and he was
measuring me up just like the guys
against the walls were and I looked at
it
and old man John said well
he was put it on
and uh
I I put it on
and there was a
a mirror
like window effect from the window you
know how you look in a window and it's
not a mirror but you can see your reflex
reflection
and
I had had an experience like 1955 when I
saw the first Outlaw Biker I ever saw on
a street corner
and I looked at myself I saw that Outlaw
Biker and then I looked and I saw John
and then I saw myself and uh
of
I turned around I was like my eyes were
like messing up and I looked at John
and
he was standing there staring at me and
I just was drawn to him and I opened my
arms up
and I went to run and embrace him and uh
he punched me in the chest
and he goes what's wrong with you he
goes never let your guard down you're a
Hell's Angel now
and that was my baptism in you know into
the club and I uh I just was like yeah
you know never let your guard down but
I'm a Hell's Angel now nothing can harm
me now later that night we got on our
motorcycles and we rode out to Betty now
do you know who Betty is Betty's this
little old woman out in San Bernardino
Purdue you know it's called in The
Outlaw culture who made handmade the
patches wow so we go out to Betty's
Betty's this old religious woman and
strict orders we get there
no smoking
and no cussing
Betty's going to put my patch on my Levi
and she's a nurse sewing it and uh
I'm just like
not only am I Hell's Angel now but Betty
sawing my patch on that she made on my
Levi vest and uh
she does all the patches
back then she's probably not even alive
anymore but she did all the patches and
you know you couldn't get a patch it was
one specific person that could order the
patches for everybody and if anybody
else tried it was you know but
uh those are the rules so we get the
pass and I try it on man and I'm you
know you can imagine how I'm feeling
John and uh I look at Betty
and she says and remember
no hot rod until you reach the end of
the street
and uh so we jumped on our bikes man and
you know that was the fastest trip from
San Bernardino to L.A we went back to
the Glendale Clubhouse you know I
partied for a few days and uh shortly
after that uh it was New Year's you know
it was December 26th we rode to Oakland
and uh I went up there and uh
my old long time uh friend animal
Paul Hibbetts who was an Oakland Hills
angel now and if you've ever seen Gimme
Shelter he's the guy with the headdress
Fox headdress on Altamonte yeah and he's
the guy he's the guy that knocked out
Marty Balin the singer from uh what's
that uh from Jefferson Airplane yeah
yeah you see the guy who stabbed the guy
up that's Alan Pizarro stabbed uh
Meredith Hunter but Meredith
you know I'm I'm actually
working with these people these two
young girls in the Bay Area that whose
their families are connected to
Altamonte somehow through the bands they
want to do a a thing uh and if it gets
off the ground those are somebody you
might want to talk to but uh
a lot of people don't realize that
Alan stabbed Meredith after Meredith
pointed the gun at the stage no I didn't
know that I didn't know that there was a
gun oh yeah he pointed the gun at the
stage and they were specifically hot you
guys were specifically higher security
Rolling Stones yeah but it you know it
Rock Scully The Grateful Dead manager
who I was good friends with
you know it just turned into a just a
mess you know like the Grateful Dead
came there they saw what was happening
uh you know Jerry Jerry I've seen that
interview Jerry's like man there's like
people getting stabbed out there yeah
Jerry you know all right you wanna go
play yeah like Jerry uh
like he he's in our movie Hell's Angels
Forever you know he goes
these guys are you know they're
they're violent in all the correct
spaces you know I don't know he said
something to that effect but you know
Jerry was the coolest dude so you hung
out with those guys yeah yeah they were
good friends of mine yeah Rob Schuller
used to call me and he'd say hey Jerry's
flying in he don't trust anybody but you
will you would you pick him up
personally I'd go down there and pick
him up at the airport now this is in the
70s
Jerry's getting off the plane with a
briefcase full of dope yeah and you know
there's no
guards you know there's he gets down off
the plane and then you know comes out
and like I go what's up Garcia he goes
oh man get me out of here there's
deadheads everywhere and uh he's telling
me I said look I got a car you just have
to know Jerry you know I knew you had to
come so you go pick up Jerry Garcia at
the airport are you are you winning your
colors I got my colors on yeah and you
go pick them up and it's like okay yeah
it's party time yeah yeah and uh so I
got a nice car for you I got a Cadillac
out here and uh he goes okay cool man
you can just get me to the car George he
goes they're deadheads everywhere there
were you know the dead cool would follow
him around yeah and uh so we get in the
car and he's he's going oh God damn it
man he goes don't make eye contact
George don't make eye contact and uh so
we get going and he goes you got to pull
into a 7-Eleven remember 7-Eleven
because you got to pull into a 7-Eleven
because I need a we gotta spray paint
the windows black
Jerry you can't spray paint the windows
I go this is a rental car man I go
you're with me man I go relax and it's
cool you know and he goes oh man I'm not
feeling cool and I go
I go do you want to change cars because
yeah so we go to my house up in Oakview
and I got a long drive up an Oak View
here yeah up here in Oakview so I got
this long driveway so Jerry Garcia was
here yeah at my path so we we pulled
down in the back yeah and uh uh
he goes oh
I don't know man he says okay I feel
better and I go come here let me show
you something so I have a van that was
the support vehicle for the hell's hand
so it's got a big motor in it but it's
really plain looking but inside it's
like a motel room you know for the kids
and the wife
so he gets in there and he goes oh man
now you remember the big old phones that
this was a house phone but it was a big
block phone that a t had you could go
outside with it if you didn't go too far
yeah so he goes can you get Scully on
the phone Rock Scully your manager and I
go yeah
so I get Scully on the phone I go hey
Scully it's yours and he is everything
okay and I go yeah Jerry wants to talk
to you man so I hand Jerry the phone
because Scully
he goes you know I've been down here one
hour George has given me everything I
need you're fire
and then of course he was joking you
know
uh so that's the kind of relationship I
had with those guys they would send me
tickets like to fly to a concert uh to
come and see him you know I haven't seen
him for a while you know I also promoted
Jerry Garcia I was the first person to
promote the Jerry Garcia band wow uh in
Southern California wow and uh you know
me and Bill Bill Graham sure finally
wound up co-promoting I mean there's
this relationship between that I mean I
remember
um you know I I know Willie Nelson a
little bit and I remember you know when
I was just the biggest fan and uh I'd go
up to San Francisco my wife was a travel
nurse up there and we we when she was my
girlfriend she broke up with me because
I was a real piece of you know
before that before you go straight down
exactly and and uh and you know man it
was awful she was a nurse up there and
she had a boyfriend and oh my God but I
would go up there all the time like
leave flowers on her car and like draw
these little stupid
yeah and she wouldn't even talk to me it
was awful but I I got these tickets
through this this this this agent uh to
to to to Willie Nelson and we got
backstage and I like rolled Willie this
giant joint and I wrote him this letter
I'm trying to get this lady back so bad
and um but I remember like we we
um this guy invited us over to the bus
but it was all hell's ain't like the
whole front row was and I mean this was
uh you know 2017. it was all Hell's
Angels and then there was this uh one
Hell's Angel with like long white hair
and he yeah oh yeah oh gee that's right
that's right and and but like talk a
little bit about that about the
relationship between that I'll tell you
a great Willie Nelson story this is back
in the 70s maybe early 80s and uh
probably about 15 of us show up at the
universal I think it's an Amphitheater
okay so either that or the Greek Theater
I think it was a universal Amphitheater
okay and
so the security guy
I go there and I go yeah we're here for
the show and he goes name and well we
never gave names I mean our backstage
pass was our patch basically that's
right and uh
I said well we're not on the list man I
go you know
we're here though he goes I'm not
letting you in
shows I go LG's uh security I go I go
come on man and uh I go okay no problem
and just about that time
Willie walks up and he goes what's the
problem
I go he won't let us in he goes well
it man we won't do the show and he
turns around we all we all turn around
with him and start walking back and the
guy goes no no Mr Nelson Mr Nelson my
mistake and you know that's the kind of
guy well he wasn't you know Waylon was
that way Willie yeah Johnny Paycheck
I've locked Johnny Paycheck in a room
one time he was so up I had to
sober him up before he went and
performed and uh he was so mad at me and
he got to the show
and uh he thinks he's going on that
night and he goes oh George it's good to
see you brother and he's all this
and you know he's going like where's the
you know and uh because there ain't
no yeah what do you mean and I go
Gotta sober up man you got to put a hell
of a show on for Toys for Tots you know
you got to do the show Saturday Saturday
it's only Thursday yeah because what am
I supposed to do in the meantime sober
up and so I locked him in the room I
left he's yelling at me I love two Hells
Angels in there with him big old Hells
Angels and uh so he went on the show did
the show Saturday thank me you didn't
say thank you for locking and you're
doing that because you want the show to
go or you're doing it for the show for
the kids
people in Santa Barbara were counting on
them at the Arlington Theater yep yep so
he uh after that every time I'd see him
he'd go you son of a you're gonna
lock me in a room I go I might Johnny
you go behave yourself I mean that's and
we have relationship Waylon Willie uh
just
you know Kris Kristofferson I met Johnny
Cash man through uh Willie and uh only
time I was ever lost for words John I
mean there was the man in Black you know
and I was just like wow yeah and he you
know he goes you know he's from up here
yeah yeah man and he saw the Ventura on
me and he looked and he goes Ventura huh
because I spent a little time in Ventura
and I go I know you did you know and I
just let him talk I just wanted to uh
hear what he had to say what do you
think that's about the the relationship
between these guys were Outlaws man I
mean these guys were Outlaws you know I
mean and really the Grateful Dead too I
don't know oh yeah you know it's like
they think it's like these hippies like
that's Outlaw man well I'll tell
you a great story about
when they went to Silver they did an
intervention on Jared you want to hear
this story I'd love to so Bob seidman is
a famous
Rock photographer if you look him up
people you don't know his name but it
you know his works if you look at the uh
Blind Faith album cover with the girl
with the no top on holding the airplane
I don't know if you remember that one
sure Bob Simon took that photograph yeah
and uh
you know year after year it's always in
the top 100 albums of all time
so they sent Bob up
for the intervention so Bob arrives on
Friday the interventions Sunday so
it was you know Jerry this is Bob
telling me the story uh
Jerry you know I'm here man you know
let's party so they're doing
heroin LSD uh weed uh opium they're
doing this whole
gig
so Sunday at four there's a knock on the
door and it's the band Bob Weir and you
know Mickey Hart and uh
it's an intervention man Jerry was
that's the farthest thing from his mind
because him and Bob had been parties on
weekends and uh they uh they did an
intervention and you know he was they
said Jerry never Jerry's most
sweetest guy on the earth you know but
he was sideman you know
you dirty you know he was
you know he was taking him out of the
party yeah and they they did they took
him to the uh rehab place and uh he got
sober and uh you know I remember when he
died I was in Sturgis man and uh you
know I took it real hard I bet you know
he was just
I remember taking him to Santa Barbara
one time we were talking about Billy
Idol and he was uh you know it's
interesting a lot of these guys become
such big icons they kind of lose touch
they can't go out uh they become
prisoners of you know of their own I
know exactly what you mean you know what
I'm talking about they come prisoners of
their own celebrity and uh
he I said yeah Billy Idol was up here a
couple of weeks ago we were talking
about different things and he goes yeah
what's he like man he goes I really like
his music I know he's cool man you know
and I go
I go the girls are throwing their
panties on the stage Jerry and he goes
wow because imagine if they uh did that
for me you know it was just just off the
wall statement yeah and I mean just the
mind of Jerry Garcia you know and you
know there's a interview of me I was a
guest disc jockey on a t on a radio show
in Ventura and I did an hour
interview
of Garcia and I was pre-taped but
there's an hour interview floating
around somewhere really a man Garcia and
I can't find it I'm getting ready to go
through all my archives I got so much
John you know go through all my
archives and I've got these uh
I've got these tapes of all these
informants like taping me you know like
in the discovery motion and I think
somewhere in those tapes Sagittarius I
got to go through it all talk a little
bit George just about uh about this
place uh you know I mean this this place
means a lot to to me me and my family
and I know it has quite a quite a
reputation here Lodge man yeah so you
know watched it uh uh change hands but
not change uh uh mission statement if
you will and I'll tell you uh in
1977 78 I started
pressing on John
and
look things were so bad in L.A you
couldn't go anywhere because of the war
because of the war so I I went to John
and I said John
I said I just want you to hear me out I
said I don't want you to think you'll
love me for this
I said we need to make a tactical
retreat
he said what do you mean I said look
you're more military I'm a marine
Department of Defense
I go I think we need to move out of this
area I said Ventura's just waiting for
us man I go it's wide open there's seven
bike clubs up there I go we go up there
and the whole court and straighten
everything out we can make the perfect
Hells Angel environment for ourselves
what makes a perfect Hell's Angel
environment
whatever we say goes I'm just being
honest uh you know friction yeah you
know it's just you know say what you
mean and mean what you say and uh a lot
of people wouldn't agree with that uh in
other bike clubs law enforcement and
even some of the community uh fathers
but you know I had a vision for this
place of it being a safe place a a
beautiful place for to ride look at this
place we're riding motorcycles man
so I say to John so I bring animal in on
it and my idea is
the Satan slaves have been talking about
becoming Hell's Angels for years so my
idea is
the Satan slaves become Hell's Angels
simultaneously we moved to Ventura the
people investigating us for all the
stuff that went on down there suddenly
don't realize we moved to Ventura
because law enforcement didn't
communicate back then they didn't share
anything Ventura county is a whole
different world yeah yeah and I said we
go up to Ventura we start fresh I said
it'll take them 10 years to figure it
out and it did and they did figure it
out and their indictments came later but
that's a whole different story
so got Satan slaves animal got the
Oakland heavyweight Sunny Foo Griffin uh
different people to endorse the Satan
slaves
patching over to Hell's Angels
so John and I come up with this idea
we're going to have a run
at Wheeler's Gorge and we're going to
introduce
Hell's Angels Ventura
Hells Angels at large to Ventura County
yeah so you guys all go meet it with me
this gorgeous is like a big
waterfall I mean yeah yeah we just went
up there and partied man for the weekend
the cops were going crazy I can't even
imagine yeah it was just incredible this
is 1977. I've got a I think I have a
poster in my pictures I'll send this
to you I'll text you and send them
to you you'll love to see you man but
so
that's how Ventura County got introduced
to you know about 300 California Hells
Angels uh coming here and partying and
everybody just swarmed in this place you
know and you know what
I think they like this
um here I am you know 40 50 years later
I don't know how long it's been 1977 you
know we're going into 2023 and what
about this place specifically well
you know I mentioned when I got here you
know Beverly and I came and saw uh
Bill Callahan here last week I mean
incredible lyrics uh incredible
performance uh you know I've been coming
here they had the house band they used
to have this band called Studebaker
uh uh that just kicked ass uh then you
had the bombers uh later that was a band
a big local these are local bands now
you've got charmand yeah who's uh
Beverly's grandson's the bass player for
Charmander oh really yeah and we were
just up here
what a week ago was this place was this
a Hells Angels yeah this was one of our
bars yeah you know you you know like
right there there's a there's a there's
a safe down there I mean that's sort of
what the rumor is like right there
that's a safe where you guys used to
keep stuff well it's a tunnel oh it's a
tunnel
well there's 16 Mongols down there
exactly yeah yeah don't go down there
George exactly you know you know what we
do we'll get go Hollywood and we'll open
the vault there you go there you go
there you go stuff his ass in it
uh my house
one of the informants
told law enforcement he was trading
information to get out of his problem
and uh
and along with the information he was
getting money and whatnot and so I don't
know where he pulled it I said there was
a body buried in my house in Oakview and
uh
when I got back from prison in Texas I
wanted to go by there and reminisce and
uh
they flattened the whole house they took
out the pool all the structures dug up
the land looking for the body wow and
needless to say there's nobody there but
uh it
this is you know this is
you know people you know you get in the
courtroom and the prosecutors you know
you know they say well you've got to
make a deal with the devil to get these
kind of guys you know and they truly are
making a deal with the devil because
these guys have no morals no ethics uh
you know they're not doing this because
they've got religion or they've had an
epiphany that they want to do the right
thing for society these guys are doing
this because they got themselves in the
jam and they want to get out of it they
want to extract themselves from their
own judicial problems and they want
money in the process you're talking
about guys yeah yeah you know and and
for and for a while there you know when
you left and you went into bad standing
you know my response to them was
well if I was an informant don't you
think all the high Echelon guys would be
locked up right now and I go has anybody
got in trouble plus you're still right
here yeah I mean right here you're not
running for me anymore I won't run from
anybody and you know whether that's good
or bad or indifferent uh uh I don't mean
any disrespect to anyone and I'm not
challenging anybody but I got nothing to
hide I didn't do anything wrong you know
I was offered a lot of money John by the
government uh to become a witness they
said their exact words or we know you
know where the bodies are buried you
name what do you want this was in 2011
when I got arrested and uh
they had a tape recorder on the table
and they said there's a murder contract
make a deal with this and we'll push
play and you can hear uh who's
conspiring against you in your own club
and I looked at him and I said you know
what I'll take my chances on the street
because I know how those guys operate
they're very duplicit they have their
own agenda and uh
when they're done with you
they're done with you that's right yeah
that's right and your code's your code
yeah absolutely I mean you know I uh
lived on this street by the codes of the
street and that's how I want to go out
and uh you know I write these books uh I
don't compromise anybody and what I say
and uh I am going to say a few things uh
in this new book but the people the
players are dead you know they can't uh
indict them and I'll tell you
historically in the criminal world when
uh
somebody dies they wind up taking the
heat for everybody oh he did everything
you know I didn't do anything it's the
standard uh saying so you know I've
never I didn't compromise anybody on uh
Outlaw Chronicles I didn't compromise
anybody on my stage play uh what's the
uh what's the biggest misconception
about the Hell's Angels or the The
Outlaw Biker world
well I think there's you know the dirty
clothes is you know something that left
ages ago decades ago sharing our women
that was never saw that happening I mean
uh certainly provocative women in the
club but you know not anybody's wife or
girlfriend uh
and I'm not saying anything bad about
those provocative women who they are
never compromise anybody I don't want
anybody to get in trouble
for me and I'll tell you
you know
guy I mentioned guy earlier Castle on uh
from this he was the president of San
Diego probably one of the fiercest guys
I've ever met
No Nonsense uh as a leader he led from
the front and I just was writing about
him last week so he's on my mind but
went to prison for machine gun in
jingles and Redbeard off their bikes on
the freeway um who did it yeah he's the
one who did it you know what did the
time for it and uh
he till the very end I was told he died
of cancer here a couple years ago he
would stand up in the meetings anytime
they say anybody said anything
derogatory about me and he goes when are
you guys going to wake up he goes we'd
all be in jail if he was doing that
stuff he goes what's wrong with you man
and he goes you know where he's at he's
not hiding I know where he's at
and he goes let's stop this and
uh you know I
a member that communicated with me after
he called me and told me a guy died and
he just said I want you to know he goes
Guy back to you till the end yeah and uh
and I said yeah and I you know I think
about him often you know gorgeous guy
was his name good looking uh Italian guy
you know you know we we started off the
conversation you guys are talking about
kids and I I'm just wondering can you
just talk to me a little bit about uh
fatherhood and I we mentioned you know
one one of your daughters represented
you uh you know I'm I'm interested in
how that felt uh what was it like to
raise kids in that world you said you
know your son your son was a member you
know uh it was very complex it's a
delicate Balancing Act
and uh I'll tell you uh
I am very open-minded
uh I like my children
as I like the women in my life to be
their own person you know uh to Blossom
and uh to follow their own path
I
my daughter I'll tell you an example
when the war was going on
with the Mongols
my first wife Cheryl my high school
sweetheart who Beverly was good friends
with as well
was getting on me she goes you know this
club thing is taking over your life you
spend no time with us I read about all
this stuff in the newspapers I hear
about it on the radio TV won't talk
about it
she goes who are we now you know you
know so I
wanted to show her who I was you know I
wanted to spend some time with him and
you know I was just
the Hell's Angel lifestyle I so I go
down I always drove a real low key type
vehicle you know I still do to this day
but uh I actually don't have a vehicle
this day I when I left to Spain I didn't
drive in Spain for three years and I
kind of liked coming back
starting over but anyways I'm getting
off track
so I took the kids to Santa Monica took
them to the pier on the Carousel and you
know all that stuff
and on the way home
I was driving with the family and uh
some guy cut me off once
cut me off again
gave me the finger
you know I'm just biting my tongue
drawing you know you can imagine I'm in
my 20s I'm in the midst of this War uh
I want to spend a nice quiet day with
the family and uh
give you some insight into my daughter
in my relationship with my daughter
uh
the guy cut me off slammed his brakes on
it was a car in front of him
and then he turned around he gave me the
finger you know that's it I can't take
it no more so I jumped out of the car he
rolled the window up and he's giving me
the fingers too but he made a an error
he forgot to lock the door
so I opened the door you know I pull him
out at a 45 degree angle give him a
couple of head slams and work him over
and you know I get back in the car and
you know now my wife Cheryl's like this
like looking at me fuming you know
Georgie's he doesn't know what's going
on you know he's a little kid and
there's Mariah like this on the looking
at me through the I'm driving I'm
looking at the mirror she just like
won't take her eyes off me it's been
like 20 15 20 minutes
and I'm looking at her and then she
finally breaks a little smile you know
and I was like I get it Dad you know so
she understands me you know and uh you
know it's interesting she graduated from
uh law school she was the youngest
graduate ever in past the California
bars he was 22.
uh the feds immediately ATF specifically
were trying to figure out a way they
went to the uh you know Bar Association
and we're trying to hold back our
license they go you can't give this girl
a license her dad is so-and-so and you
know they said to their benefit you know
uh they said well we're not going to
punish her for his sins you know she's
her own person and uh
she just
started in this career of criminal
defense she was going to be a doctor
initially she's a Puget the University
of Puget Sound and she calls me up
this is after I got found guilty not
guilty in my murder trial in 1987.
she's getting ready to go to college
and she calls me up and she says Hey Dad
uh how would you feel about me coming
home
I'm like oh you're always welcome
home like what's going on I've been
are you having problems in school she
goes no she goes but I've been doing a
lot of thinking and she goes I think I
want to be a defense attorney
yeah the I said the defense attorney
she goes yeah she goes I don't like what
they did to her family wow and uh she
came home and uh went to law school and
uh
graduated like I said at 22 past the bar
you know she's worked with some of the
best lawyers uh around
and we'll go back on Taco now Taco had
been in prison about five years he was
doing a life racketeering he was doing
life and he was also doing 10 years for
ordering my murder
so he had the life sentence that he had
the 10-year racketeering sense and he
called my daughter
and he goes caught me excuse me he
called me and said you know you're uh
your daughter's doing uh unbelievable
things I hear
because you're still on the street after
a 59 count indictment and uh he goes how
would you feel about her assisting my
wow attorney yeah and I I said who's
your attorney and he told me Henry
Gonzalez I think out of Florida a very
well known attorney
and I thought about it for a minute I
said you know what Taco why not and uh I
said but I got to ask you a question
before you get off the phone
he was okay and I said look I know you
got a racketeering
life sentence and I said I know you got
10 years
for that hit on me I go what are you
going to do first the tender the life
and just you I said good talking to
your taco
but uh so you know I mean she's she
really created a niche for herself
George Christie III uh was a Hell's
Angel he was my vice president for a
while
uh
you know he got voted in on the same day
I got voted in our anniversaries were uh
together you know he was in the club
over a decade he left the club
because of how they treated me and when
I say he left the club he's not the only
one that left the club there's could
name off about 15 guys rapid session at
uh concession that decided uh if this is
how they're going to treat George after
uh 35 years 40 years
I don't want any part of it
but uh he uh
great kid you know
he was interesting he had to
following his sister's footsteps his
sister was a straight A student uh just
she you know shy of a genius maybe a
genius uh and uh
why can't you be like your sister I get
that constantly got that sure and he had
a learning disability
and uh it uh it was tough on him
he uh
somehow had lung problems and uh
he was 39 he uh I talked to him on the
phone he had the flu
he thought what he had was pneumonia and
he went to sleep and never woke up one
shut down in his sleep uh you know I
talk about him in my uh
stage play I had a dream about him after
he died and uh very
profound dream
and uh I wrote it into the play you know
it's part of the
Final Act uh
and
you know I miss him
you know it's interesting Beverly was
talking about
of we've known each other since we were
12 and you know we've been friends or
families were friends I was best friends
with her husband of 56 years he just
died a few years ago
and our sons were were friends best
friends and her son died as well at 39.
so uh
you know we belong to a club that no
parents should have to belong to that's
right you don't want to bury your
children
I have a
a transgender child I've never talked
about it publicly so you're getting a
scoop here John and I
I'm an old school guy
I don't if I'm going to insult you
you're going to know it that's right but
I do sometimes I misgender her
his friends
and uh probably one of the most
incredible artists
at age 10.
I had to take the lights out of their
bathroom
because they were in their uh they would
get epiphanies to do uh these art
projects and uh the only way I could
stop him was to take the light out of
the bathroom so he couldn't turn the
light on and work I'd get up at three or
four in the morning I'd hear something
and they would be in the bathroom and
they would did claymation I have a
claymation they did probably age 10 or
11 of uh someone being led to solitary
confinement and the doors shut
uh the uh
just the art that they draw is just
incredible in fact uh
they are so good
The Producers for Outlaw Chronicles uh
used uh them in the graphic design for
the show they actually went uh they said
to me we're going to get somebody to do
this and I said well I think I have
somebody for you and on their own Merit
they got the job and you know flew back
with me and uh you know did a lot of the
graphics and that look around how old
how old is he just gonna turn 30. turn
30 at this this year we'll turn 30. you
know you know I don't know I'm going to
say this and maybe I'll put my foot in
my mouth
to this is to parents
a minute
this is the parents of the transgender
child
you know you think you're going through
problems imagine what that child's going
through and the biggest hurt for me
was
having to say goodbye to my daughter
and then reintroducing ourselves as my
son and I don't know if that sounds
corny
uh I and I hope I don't offend anybody
from that Community uh you know I love
Aubry
incredible person you know and uh now
we'll get to my youngest
Finn
the rocket scientist who takes after my
uncle
and you know he's autistic he didn't
speak till he was five he somehow
come out of it talk about a master
negotiator uh
he doesn't like to be around a lot of
people so he created a this uh
he went to Chaparral School up here and
petitioned them to uh
to give him a spot there and he
explained his situation you know he
doesn't like to be around a lot of
people things come in very fast for him
with his autism
and uh
they said no we can't help you well next
day I got a phone call
they said just Mr Christie and I said
yeah this could you send your son Finn
over we want to talk to him so he went
back over there negotiated himself a
spot in that school
during the course of that
he built his first computer I think he
was 14 at the time when he built his
computer and then he
got interested in physics and problems
and he created this problem and he he
asked me to take a look at it I'll tell
you John I had no idea what I mean it's
this I'll send you a picture of it it's
like this might as well send me I won't
know yeah so they thought
possibly he was making this stuff up
that it didn't have any uh
wasn't anything it's just numbers anyway
it was putting together they sent it to
uh somebody local up here and I got a
phone call from this
you know mathematician and he said who
taught him this
and I said taught him what and they go
who taught him how to do these
mathematics and I go he taught himself
on the computer he started researching
it he goes this guy's he's a
mathematician he gives where does this
stuff come from I said you have to ask
him I said I don't even know what he's
doing I would go come in the house and
there would be
problems on the mirrors on the windows
with Grace pan well he'd be doing all
these things on the grease board and I
went to one of his problems and I erased
one of the numbers and
like a kid I did a Dickie bird you know
the dicky bird is
he comes out and he said to me I'm in
the front room and he comes out and he
goes
did you do this
and I go guilty and he goes you need to
grow up man
so you know those are my kids in a
nutshell I love them all they're all
unique and like I mentioned earlier
they're all from a different decade yeah
they're just like
yeah you got kids man yeah just like
little little humans man right that's
what they are yeah
uh you know I don't know John you know
it uh life is strange man and uh you
know I figure
pick a set of morals
pick a uh destination
paint a vision
don't be afraid to revise it from time
to time but follow it man you know
because if you're not you're full of
that's the bottom line I guess
I don't know you know and I've some
people would argue with me I've been
accused of being full of but uh
here I here I am yeah you know and I I
don't mean that from an egotistical
standpoint I mean that from a humble
standpoint I get it you know I made a
lot of mistakes
but I every mistake I've made I've
learned from and I haven't repeated you
know or at least tried not to repeat it
there you go and uh
I uh I think Ojai you know we talked
about this place earlier Ojai have you
ever checked out the pink moment oh yeah
oh man you know this it's amazing you
know the Chumash we're up here and uh
uh
we should take a lesson from them you
know and uh what's the lesson we should
take
let nature work its course man you know
and follow your uh
follow the little voice inside you
because I think the little boy unless
you're crazy you know the Little Voices
leading to the right way that's right
and uh you know sometimes it's a
struggle you know you want to tell them
to shut up
that's right that's why you tell them to
shut up yeah you don't want to hear what
they're saying because you know they're
right yeah you know yeah
um thanks man I really appreciate this
you uh you you have anything you have
anything else for me or well we always
want to thank you okay and you know what
I've been around a lot of uh celebrity
people
and uh I love it when people stay humble
ah thanks man you're a good man yeah
right back at you man it's a real it's a
real honor for me and does anybody else
have anything for for George
so this is the stage hook what's that no
no no no no
and uh no I'm teasing you man no no I
know it I know it
foreign
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world something I'm I'm just super proud
of and again grateful that you guys
tuned in we've decided we want to take
things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become part of this
community look I already bore Bam Bam if
you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
year was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you be
good to each other out there rock and
roll
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stud coordinator
from The Punisher he's coming all the
way up because we're about to get after
it and when that's done he asked me in
the car are you gonna have my shake
ready and I know what that means am I
gonna have my son Warrior Shake they've
got the active protein but they also
have this collagen protein which is
amazing they also have the warrior blend
which is a little bit lighter if you're
trying to cut and uh I believe in it I
believe in that some Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones
[Music]